c'est un des matches et c'est le rocher
percé du sud du québec
[Musique]
l'image appartient à tous
tous donc on est pas prêt à vous et moi
on est propriétaire de sous mais ça
dépend effectivement de l'activité la
propriétaire du terrain
[Musique]
oh
des gens s'arrêtent le voit on voit que
cherche la fenêtre pour trouver
l'endroit à partir duquel prendre une
photo et puis c'est devenu de plus en
plus respirer si l'on peut bien voir
l'abbaye de saint-benoît-du-lac et les
collines environnantes
c'est en grande partie grâce à
l'agriculture à quelques pas d'ici
le oui au pays d'animaux pour ne pas
faire de coupes de bois ce site c'est
incroyable la rapidité avec laquelle les
paysages se refaire je prends de
l'intérêt nécessairement des ressources
financières éventuellement parce que si
on n'a pas de projet d'agriculture
parce qu'on oppose la relève parce qu'on
a police ou parce qu'on a pas l'intérêt
qui le fait le problème c'est qu'au
québec la notion de paysage ne fait pas
partie des plans d'aménagement des
différentes municipalités les paysages
ne sont pas gérées comme un bien commun
le territoire d'abord perçue comme une
ressource une ressource agricole ou une
ressource forestière de ressources
hydrauliques etc
le territoire le paysage est façonné bon
parcours différents ministères et mme
cyr l'agriculture ce que l'agriculture
hydro-québec ce que de transmettre de
l'énergie le mtq s'occupe du transport
mais y'a personne qui s'occupe de tout
seul
les paysages évolue donc augurer des
volontés des propriétaires terriens
qu'il soit gouvernementaux ou privés le
territoire est souvent laissé en pâture
un peu à qui le possède
en restant dans la réglementation qui
existe évidemment restant dans les
limites dans les balises de la loi ou
des règlements on peut faire à peu près
ce qu'on veut un endroit
[Musique]
mais dans plusieurs régions on veut que
ça change
il de verchères en plein milieu du saint
laurent une délégation d'un ménage east
et de représentants de la mrc marguerite
d'youville vont à la découverte de cet
archipel seront plus protégés de la
modifie beaucoup l'a confié philippe
roussel fait partie du groupe
il a pour mission de documenter ce qu'il
voit partout dans la mrc pour bâtir ce
que l'on appelle un atlas de paysages ça
c'est un gros ouvrage de caractérisation
des paysages donc on cherche à connaître
chacun des paysages qui sont présents
sur la mrc on cherche à les qualifier
allez comprendre à comprendre comment il
évolue comme un commun existe on parle
de paysages agricoles le paysage
forestier de paysages aussi de milieux
humides
on parle du paysage fluvial des
archipels et on parle aussi dans
marguerite d'youville le paysage
suburbains ca jazz de paysages sont un
nouvel outil d'aménagement du territoire
l'idée vient d'europe ils ont pour but
de bien documenter le territoire
présents et passés de comprendre les
usages humains en lien avec la
géographie et l'écologie il vise à aider
les aménagistes et les urbanistes à
favoriser un meilleur développement
territorial
c'est une approche où on regarde d'où on
vient donc le paysage s'est constitué
comment dans le passé
où
mieux on connaît notre paysage pu par la
suite on peut raffiner nos outils et
avoir une meilleure adhésion sur ce
qu'on veut faire en terme
d'interventions par la suite sur deux
territoires
c'est de dépasser le cadre du beau du
laid donc ne travaille pas pour espérer
faire du joli on travaille pour espérer
faire de l'harmonieux on n'est plus dans
la reconnaissance des qualités des
potentiels des différents paysages pour
pouvoir mieux les planifier déplaçons
nous cette fois à rivière-ouelle au bas
saint laurent
[Musique]
ici on veut être les premiers à obtenir
une nouvelle désignation au québec celle
d'un paysage culturel patrimonial
le projet vise l'ensemble de ce que l'on
appelle la pointe aux orignaux on arrive
en fait waouh
il ya vraiment des caractéristiques
particulières à la fois géographique
parce qu'il ya un cap rocheux puis on
voit tout le territoire mais y'a mon mr
et qui est du patrimoine bâti et donc
des vieilles maisons ancestrales
il ya toute la notion de villégiature
donc les gens se sont installés au 19e
siècle il ya aussi la pêche à l'anguille
est donc un savoir-faire donc différents
éléments qui caractérisent un paysage
remarquable
[Musique]
nous autres on perd chez seat depuis
1769 ça fait deux cent cinquante et un
astéroïde puis on a toujours fait subi
pas mal de cette façon au loup ya eu
certaines améliorations avec un thème et
c'est oui on fait partie du territoire
ont fait partie du patrimoine
ça donne rien changé quelque chose pour
changer pour de moderniser ou moi j'aime
mieux ça reste comme celle à cette
désignation de paysage culturel
patrimonial n'apporte pas de budget
précis ni de protection intégrale c'est
avant tout une façon d'orienter le
développement c'est pas obligé d'avoir
des millions $ pour faire des gestes au
quotidien et d'avoir collectivement une
vision de ce qu'on veut en termes de
développement paysages et de protection
de patrimoine bâti de cette intégration
tous ces éléments là sur un territoire
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec notre
agriculture nos pêche à l'anguille à la
place par exemple de s'approprier toutes
les rives du fleuve construire des
maisons comme son et à laval ben il ya
une question d'harmonisation une
question de qualité de vie et donc ce cd
geste qui peut se faire au niveau
réglementaire ça mais c'est le citoyen
qui doit aussi s'approprier et d'être
conscients de la valeur le paysage est
un bien collectif
[Musique]
pour que le paysage devienne un
véritable bien collectif
[Musique]
il faudra développer une vision commune
sur la valeur et les enjeux de
développement qui affectent ses paysages
quand on regarde où les gens s'implante
c'est pas aléatoire c'est notamment
profiter du paysage
donc le paysage est une ressource une
ressource à la fois comme cadre de vie à
la fois pour le titre et touristique
c'est une ressource importante mais ce
n'est pas reconnu y'a pas de porter de
paysages au québec
[Musique]
en france en particulier gens sont
encore très proches de leurs territoires
sont proches de leur terroir sont
proches de leurs produits locaux
vous allez avoir une multitude de lieux
dits de deux amours des villages nommer
ici ça prend tout sur une route pour qu
on annonce qu'on traverse rameau même
s'il a mouillé la qui existe
[Musique]
il faut comprendre que l'agriculture ne
produit pas que des biens alimentaires
la forêt ne produit pas que des deux
parcs ap
ce sont des milieux qui produisent de
multiples choses et profiter des
paysages
toutes ces idées d'atlas ou de statut de
paysage culturel patrimonial marque peut
être le début d'une révolution dans la
compréhension et dans la gestion de
notre territoire
on voit de ces bêtes là mais c'est pas
juste ça propulsés principaux juste du
boeuf s'est produit du paysage les gens
viennent apprécié et c'est ça qu'il faut
le reconnaître dans cette espèce de
multifonctionnalité du territoire qu'on
on voit encore à travers des lots très
très spécifiques et des 6 août rend très
spéciaux
[Musique]
vous